Before we finish this lesson,
I wanted to summarize things and
tell you how this all fits in
to machine learning for trading.
The first thing to point out here is
that bagging and boosting are just
methods for taking existing learners and
essentially wrapping them in this
meta algorithm that converts your
existing learner into an ensemble.
And you should use the same
API to call your ensemble
that you would have earlier been
using to call an individual learner.
So externally, to whatever part of
your program is calling the learner,
it doesn't know that underneath there
you're doing boosting or bagging.
Your resulting learner is also likely
to lower error and reduced overfitage.
So to summarize, boosting and
bagging are not new algorithms in and
of themselves.
They're meta algorithms that
let you wrap your underlying
learning algorithms into
something that's better.
Okay, that's it for this lesson.
I will see you again soon.
Bye bye.